This puts us in a good position to be able
to go back to that question we looked at before,
so let's look at it a little bit differently this
time. If our hypothesis space is the set of functions that
take 10 bit inputs and there is a hypothesis corrisponding
to returning each of those 10 bits, seperate hypthesis, one
returns the first bit, one returns the second bit. And
so on, and now we have a target of Epsilon equals
point 1, so we would like to, return a hypothesis whose error is less
than or equal to point 1, and we want to be pretty sure of it,
the error, or failure probability needs to be less than or equal to point
2, and let's just say for concreteness,
that our distribution of our imput is uniform.
>> Ok.
>> So given this setup, how many samples
do we need to pack learn this hypothesis set.
>> Okay.
>> And remember the algorithm that we're going to use is we're going to
draw sample of the size that we want. Then we are
going to be confident that we've epsilon exhausted that, that, version space.
And so anything they left in the version space should have low
error. And that procedure should fail with probability, no more than .2.
>> Right. So it's just exceeds probability .8.
>> Yeah.
>> Or. Better.
>> Okay, think we can work that through?
>> I think we can.
>> Alright let's do it.
>> Okay. Cool.